all right today's first topic uh Billy
ish being a woman is just a war forever
especially being a young woman in the
public eye it's really unfair I wasn't
trying to have people not sexualize me
when I was wearing those oversized
clothing but I didn't want people to
have access to my body even visually I
wasn't strong enough and secure enough
to show it if I had shown it at the time
I would have been completely devastated
if people had said anything okay if
you're una aware Billy's got huge
Bazookas all right so I've never felt
like a woman to be honest with you I've
never felt desirable I've never felt
feminine I have big boobs I've had big
boobs since I was nine and that's just
the way I am that's how I look you wear
something that's all revealing and
everyone's like oh but you didn't want
people to sexualize you why nobody ever
says a thing about men's bodies she says
if you're muscular cool if you're not
cool cool if you're real thin cool you
have a dad bod as a man cool if you're
pudgy love it everybody's happy with it
you know why because girls are nice they
don't give a [__] because we see people
for who they are and that got everybody
very upset I mean here I'll give you a
quick example uh
shortman we all know you know it
everybody knows it right it's not a
short get shamed for things they
literally cannot change like their
height
even in Hollywood how many actors have
had to go through extreme weight losses
to be able to land a roll or extreme
weight gains to be able to land a roll
how many male actors talk about being
completely insecure and have to get
plastic surgery to even stay within the
industry even in the place that she
works at men have to do crazy things
just to keep up all these dudes who are
going on tour and they're doing RB
singing like yo they have to invest so
much in order to keep their bodies in
that shape because they know if they
fall out they're no longer that sex
symbol that women love a lot of the
times now is it true that ladies are
going to deal with more pressure when it
comes to their looks and it's more
important the dudes sure but I mean the
difference isn't so large that it's like
men don't have that same problem we
certainly do you as a dude you get
criticized if you're too big if you're
too buff if you're too skinny I mean I
Remember Me growing up bro everybody had
something like here's the thing I'm
going to say something that's even spicy
it is acceptable to say anything you
want to a man in regards to their body
100% 100% because we have that
perception that me people are nice to
men and that men are not affected by
like body image issues people feel
comfortable 100% uh and I know this
especially true if you're on the skinny
side that's even 10 times more true
people just come up and be like [__]
you need food it's like who are you they
just come out and say [__] like that all
the time family friends people I don't
even [__] know I was like yo this so
normal because they don't even see like
they don't even think that skinny people
could have body image issues and then
all this stuff is so normalized you see
it all the time and and dudes do it to
each other women do it to men uh you
know he's oh he's too skin I want I want
a guy who I feel like strong or safe
around right women have all these
standards about like height or I don't
want him to be like smaller than me like
even just like girth wise or whatever
this is there's all kinds of stuff men
get shamed for the size of their
penis like that is common stuff this
idea that oh women are just nice like no
it's not true some women are nice some
women are not some men are nice people
are nice some people are not that's it
but this idea that like you know being a
man and like I can tell you this right
now 95% of the male viewers watching
right now have body image issues 100%
okay but they go to the gym and they
stop body of course you're always
thinking about like are my shoulders big
enough I do Jaws bigger than mine and
more chiseled oh my forehead forehead
you know whatever it might be everybody
pick your poison
everybody got body image issues and
ain't gendered just cuz men ain't out
here always crying about it trust me in
forums and stuff like that yo listen you
want to know how nerdy these [__] are
bro they were starting to do ratios to
find like the perfect male figure they
started naming them Chads oh he got a
Chad jaw they they they they they
started doing like math they started
doing [__] math to find the perfect
ratio between like the jawline into
coming into this portion to the
cheekbones and they're like this person
has a techn like dude's obsessed over it
I know cuz I spent so much time in male
forums it is actually completely gay how
much they obsess over it
you be like I've never I didn't know
dudes could stare at other man this face
and like disgust it amongst each other
yay the body image issues are real super
real so all this to say uh you know when
you see dudes putting stuff in their
body right so they can give themselves
The Edge when it comes to lifting body
image issues right they want to reach
that Peak because they feel like they're
not enough if they don't so they're
taking their performance to the next
level it's not a critique I'm not
judging nobody do what you got to do
okay but best Bel those kinds of
comments and those kinds of negative
comments we get it all the time
sometimes for men sometimes for I see
dudes y like yo you need to lift more
your back not big
enough Abba decided to get me you know
he wanted me to get an upgrade so he got
me the parliament it's kind of nice I
got to admit but one thing I noticed on
the wallet is that ABBA wrote his name
on it his gift to me is me thinking
about
him yes I did that and I don't even
regret it you think I'm out here just
giving gifts to people so they can go
off later on and pretend like I didn't
give it to them do I look like a new
fool No I gave it to you but you better
remember it yeah that's how I do my
gifts with a string attached today's
video is brought to you by extra listen
I partner for these guys on the cheap
cuz I [__] love what they make these
you guys saw the previous one I gifted
it to a bunch of the homies every single
one of them still use it and loves using
them
[Music]
[__] list I be on dates and when it's
time to pay for the bill I be
like
[__] y feel like James bonding this
[__] okay love this you can hold up to
14 cards total if you want to use a
strap on the inside uh great fabric it
feels solid I've never had issues on the
inside I actually don't put extra cards
I put an air tag right here why think
about this I lost my wallet twice just
popped it on my phone bam okay this has
been a lifesaver I have saved so much
I've already paid for the wallet itself
just by having the tracking device on it
if you want to up your game go to the
link in the description below use code
Abba and preach and get 55% off 55 I was
looking up at what age Billy iish got
successful and and she she want her
first Grammy at
13 um and when that
happens you kind of don't live the
normal 13year old life and the rest of
your life is not really going to be
necessarily the same and I think that
it's just that some people like that and
that live in that realm that are super
popular and everything is stuff are
often times disconnected about what
reality well what reality what most of
the people live and feel they are often
sheltered and they don't view everything
that we're we get access to sometimes
and I think that's what it is I think
she is not connected to what normal
people feel and see and stuff like that
cuz it's not the first time that I see
Billy Alli say some St some stuff that
I'm
like you don't sound like you know what
you're talking about but I understand
it's just really the experience of
someone being remote and being a star at
a young age often times these people are
really disconnected you kind of become
sort of a politician like you're not
connected really with the people do
people talk about that BS absolutely do
we do girls talk about if the guy is too
skinny yes yes they do but I don't think
she saw that I don't think she has
access to what we had access or maybe
she's just delusional or not connected
at all but yeah all of those things that
you said that you think it's cool and
everything and stuff it's
not women talk about oh yo look look at
the beauty standards for women yeah look
at the Barbie and stuff like that have
you seen a GI
Joe they have muscles at places we don't
have places have you seen any superhero
that's out
there sometimes they feel like if you're
not Jason Momoa you're for the trash
you're for the street nobody going to
want you I've seen people I've seen girl
talk about the fact that I have or not
have abs when they have a whole ass
belly they there is people entitled out
there there is certified girls that keep
on talking about body positivity and
when you ask them would you go out with
a a guy that's big they say no cuz they
don't play that so the double standard
is really real and it's really out there
and no it's not true that everything is
fine I've seen a couple of runways of
shows of body positivity uh it was it
was swimsuit for body positivity and it
was big women there beautiful big women
that were walking down this the the the
the runway and it was a wonderful thing
and the guys that were modeling this the
the the the the their swimming suit were
people that were deck tap with 12 packs
and
PS n you know girls do care and girls
are not as nice as you think they are
they're not going to be like oh yeah
nice you don't have
a the ghost thing is done by guys a
ghosting is done by girls both ghost
both
catfish so the fact that you're telling
me that oh no girls are
nice no they're
not no they're not and most people that
are training is not to
be effective at something or strong or
strong no it's to look a certain way
true [__] I got to I got to be able to
work this muscle right okay what do I
got to cuz the inside's not as big it's
not
symet that's what we do mhm we don't
even train that for the aspect of being
functional yep but just for the look of
it that's why there's some people that
don't do like day cuz this is what we
see the most true and they go big on the
top and it looks
like yeah pipe cleaners in the bottom
you understand what I'm saying so let's
let's let's not act like y girls are
nice that that's not true yeah that
that's not true but it also it's true
that like people very hard on ladies in
regards to they looks that is 100 so the
struggle that you feel as a woman in
regards to like looking a certain type
of way whether or not you choose to
sexualize yourself or not whether you go
over the top to try to hide your body
parts because you don't want to be
constantly judged for that you want to
be judged for your talent like that's a
real struggle too all of these things
are valid I just I I would wish that
people wouldn't try to discredit the
other side in order to LED Credence to
the fact that their side struggles the
truth is The Human Experience is
struggling
man woman child old people we struggle
kids want to be understood old people
want to feel
relevant everybody going to have their
problems so we just don't need to
discredit the others that's what I was
going to say go ahead when things like
that happen often time what I see as
people are like yeah but women yeah but
men but that's not what we saying both
can coexist at the same time true like
me saying no men have it hard too it's
not saying that women don't have it hard
like both can coexist at the same same
time it's not a competition of misery
what the [__] is wrong with you it's
like sometimes sometimes it's really
that it's like you just say yeah you
know man have it too no you don't cuz
women yeah that's not what I said be
that's not even what I'm trying to say
I'm trying to say that we have it bad
but me saying we have it bad don't mean
that [__] y'all we have it bad I really
just said we B and both can be can be
there that's it [__] really
just want to be heard [__] just
really want to put their things out
there yeah it could have been a I feel
you cuz it's bad for us too uhuh it
could be that but n you just thinking
like a competition and [__] like that yo
it's Mt corny man I'll say this too if
if any of you guys are doubting me go
talk to the men in your life okay they
might not open to you right away about
their body EV issues cuz generally as
men even though we may have them we're
not open about them because then it's
admitting to insecurities that we have
but these dudes are open enough they'll
be able to tell you like yeah ask them
actually don't ask them if they have
body image issue ask them if you know
that if men around them have body images
about C do you think that men feel some
type of way about their bodies make it
more G don't make it about them
specifically I think you're going to be
very surprised to how quickly most of
them going to be like yeah definitely I
don't mean personally someone's like yo
you got body image or something like
well but if you talk me like dudes yeah
[__] out of here what take your [__]
what do you mean you got body issues you
got body insecurities why are you saying
that how do you know cuz I know how do
you know I just know no you know that's
what's what you think you're just
ascribing to me an
yeah you do you be ascribing the tent to
me that you don't even know no I know I
know you got about it's okay I don't
just admit it bro why you why you got to
be like this you always have to put a
front like I don't I don't yes you do
it's okay BR I feel great in my body I
do it's fine I do it's okay don't try to
make me feel insecure I'm not trying to
make you feel yeah you trying to put
something on me pause that sounded so
gay hey yo yeah yeah yeah don't don't
act like I no no it's fine bro you do
don't project outward I don't give [__]
just speak for yourself I'm fine with
that okay so talk about it but but don't
put it on me they know they know they
know they know they know you you don't
like it's like you got insecurities like
anybody else you I have insecurities but
not body IM issues oh that's that's a
lie but it's fine it's okay okay
Noto it's okay it's okay he's not ready
guys it's fine we not it's it's not
something that we're going to open and
that's how it is between those guys now
you see all right so everybody got their
thing so figure out what yours is you
know come to terms with it but that's
about it anything else no talk about
your body magici I'm good yeah yeah yeah
you want to talk about other people but
when it's about you all of a sudden you
want I often I often talk about I often
talk about me and whenever we talk about
you you about whenever we talk about you
that's exactly what you do you block it
off you're like you talk you talk over
people and [__] like that yeah work on
that work on that he's going to work on
that all right let's know what you guys
say in the
comments